نتواجد اليوم هنا في معسكر النيم للنازحين
بولايه شرق دارفور وهو احد معسكرات اقليمي
دارفور للنازحين الازمه السودانيه الدائره
بين الجيش والدعم السريع الغت بظلالها على
واقع المعسكر خاصه بعد خروج عدد كبير من
المنظمات العامله في الحقل الانساني كما
نتابع هنالك تكدس كبير جدا في موارد
المياه بسبب نقص الوقود وايضا بسبب عدم
وجود تشغيل لهذه المحطات التي تعمل في
مجال السقيا للمعسكر هنالك معاناه ايضا في
شتى المجالات الصحيه والانسانيه
بس دم عدم المويه الزحمه دي عدم المويه
اذا كان المويه في الزحمه ما بيكون فيه
دارينا الجاص بس يشتغل
جازي الجازي يجي والكارب يشتغل اثنين نفس
ويضم معسكر النيم للنازحين ما يزيد عن
100,000 نازح يتوزعون في مربعات محدوده
يعانون نقصا في الغذاء والدواء بسبب تدهور
الاوضاع في السودان بعد الاحداث التي حصلت
فيهم الى يومنا هذا اصبح المواطن في معسكر
النيل في مستوى واحد
كله مستوى واحد لانهم تحت السفر من حيث
المعاناه لا وجود لاي حركه بالدخل ولا في
مدخل ولا حتى الناس اللي شويه عندهم يعني
حبه اعمال تجاره شنو
معاناه بشكل يساوي تسعه وتسعين وتسعه عشره
كما يتخوف سكان المعسكر من الانفلات
الامني خاصه عمليات السلب والنهب التي
يستخدم فيها السلاح والله حصل ان نشوف جدا
والمواطنين فروا
ناس
يستقروا والله يا اخي حارب ده كده
الحرب اذا لم تعود الاوضاع في السودان الى
الواقع الذي كانت عليه ربما يتوسع شبح
المجاعه ليشمل المدن والاحياء التي تعاني
الان في جوانب عديده بجانب معسكرات النزوح
الممتده في عدد من المدن باقليم دارفور
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقص